[Musique]
j'ai déjà rencontré un super fan c'est
aussi flatteur que c'est flippant sa
grosse trace
j'ai constamment été déstabilisé par un
spectateur jusqu'à ce que je décide
d'embrasser pleinement ma myopie ce flou
qu'elle met entre moi et le monde et
d'arrêter notre mes lunettes sur sanne
nbc délicieux
j'ai constamment oublié mon texte sur
scène et c'est pour ça qu'il faut être
très à l'aise si tu as super le trac et
oublie un truc rires ne vas tu es dans
une dynamique de contrôle alors que tu
es toi-même et qui je l'oublié jason
ensemble sur autre chose et je
retomberai sur les pattes ça se passe
très bien
j'habite au cinquième 500 soeur voilà
c'est mon marathon de new york à moi
j'ai participé à quelques internautes du
jeune fille mais de gens debout de gens
élégants de gens sympas y compris le
mien est pas d'humiliation publique il
n'était pas question impérativement de
boire sur un vélo à 4 celle enfin voilà
l'été
j'étais ministre arcand natalie portman
et veut pas pour elle pour son office et
c'était très sympa sont super et portman
une pièce super je dis ça c'est à 10 ans
la pauvre d'être sous voulait que tout
laissait ce que de drôles de
référencement qui sortent natalie
portman suisse comique à chaque fois il
ya moi car mon histoire mais il était
fort sympathique je pense qu'ils se
rappellent plus de l'existence
mais non parce que la démarche du bon
coin de mettre des photos d'aller
négocier des gens qui de fait venir des
gens chez moi qui aurais donné le code
et cetera m'angoisse énormément
et bien sûr je me suis vu qu'il est un
être que d'addiction j'en ai ne faut pas
dire c'étaient des enfants qui le
regardent n'y allez pas mais essayez
parfaitement mais il faut pas le faire
mais il faut pas
ça crée énormément de déco anxiété ce
mois est à la fois je me suis résolu à
l'idée que ça ne peut pas entièrement
sur les épaules puis comme si le monde
entier attendait que marina rollmann
facettes grandes découvertes
fais ce que tu peux et après au niveau
de ce que vraiment ça n'est pas dans tes
mains voilà peut-être pas tous exposés
est ce vraiment si grave vidéo
interactifs et pire la faut savoir
partir
mais pas qu figurez vous je n'allais pas
je cherche constamment n'hésitez pas à
m'en vais au maire de brest il ya un psy
que j'adore règne quoi l'essayer il
avait à team bikers et de risques il
avait énormément de créneaux de nip / dr
donc j'allais le voir sur google maps et
l'agent 2 points 3 sur 5 c'est que des
messages d'insultés il m'a reçu ivre il
avait la braguette ouverte il fumé
pendant la séance et m'a insulté et je
réfléchis tu
mets tous les jours que dieu fait j'ai
un problème avec ça toutes les trois
semaines chat mais finalement c'est
devenu prof en primaire s'il faut je
donne du sens à tout ça j'ai fait une
pause je suis devenu céramiste je
travaille chez des fleuristes sont
représentés les acariens pas son
professeur
j'ai complètement joué dans la salle de
mairie c'est le paradis latin vous
pouvez retrouver les joints en captation
souvine dans un spectacle drôle m oui
ouais bah voilà c'était la salle nommée
ravallec elle est belle et glamour et
mystérieuse est plein de poussière c'est
tout moi
[Musique]